- welcome Super Troopers and mom army
today welcome to it's a good way to
start the show
excuse man welcome to the number one
place for news viral hits and weekly
gaffes do you like that approach I'm
trying to brand the show and as a
current event show welcome everybody to
the number one place for news viral hits
a weekly gaps on your own ethnic line
what do you think I don't know if I like
it I'll have to think about you on it
because it's true we are the number one
place in the world it's not the most
humble intro it's not we are the number
one place in the universe from viral
hits well who else is competing on
weekly gaffes specifically those two
words competition so I think I can claim
without pomp or posture that I am Number
One today's episode we don't have
sponsors so guys we're gonna need you
all to enjoy our very special made a
video by to promote Teddy fresh coms
newest summer collection of which this
shirt is a member as well as the bucket
hats and what he was wearing we put
together a whole Teddy fresh show with
the crew we don't run what's fun is it's
actually fun so you're gonna want to
stay tuned for that we got a lot to get
to today
this is so the Belle Delphine story must
can always continue to develop in some
way and we had a really interesting
email from a fan who who kind of did a
little Sherlock homing on why her stab
it may have smelled of alcohol so we've
got a test
we got a actual blood-alcohol saliva
test that we're gonna do a test on her
saliva and see if is there alcohol and
how much is there and we're gonna try to
dye solutes and also I sent a sample to
23andme no no I'm kidding
would that be creepy though very creepy
we've also got a Linna tea throwing cats
we've got cats that trailer cats
everywhere
but before that guys you know apparently
if you're listening on the podcast
iTunes or Google Play or whatever if you
leave a review
apparently that makes a big difference
so mom are me Super Troopers it's time
to mobilize get out there
smash that five star leave a review
apparently it makes a difference I don't
know I bet you if you all go smash that
we'll be number one on iTunes they don't
care about actual streams they just want
reviews they want they want to see Super
Troopers mobilized to interesting yeah I
think that really does matter so help a
brother out next up we've got okay
you've all heard me talking about
Instagram food I'm obsessed with
Instagram food I'm always finding the
weirdest [ __ ] on there specifically the
Turkish guys are up to some weird
business every time on Instagram and I
have been polling examples for months
and I have to ask first of all what's
there's David they eat this food in
Turkey that I do not know it's very
popular people like this and it's looks
so disgusting
and I don't even know what it is like if
I had where yeah if I had to guess it's
like a well after watching fear factor
affecting everybody know what it is well
like a penis
yeah or like it definitely looks like
the cow intestine it looks like some
kind of like it looks like a sperm sac
or something yeah I mean it looks like
some future body part but I see kids
getting down with a girl like everybody
this is like a like look how he presents
it damn what are your thoughts on that
as a vegetarian look how he's touching
the block I don't know what it is though
I always license music that's playing by
the way okay how do I meet it okay
everybody for you everybody wrote in and
said
yes I know I did mute sight where's the
listeners are very smart well I don't
really have options so very funny what
am I gonna mute sight does a mute I
didn't you say that's it then yes
they're the best they have huge dicks
too and deep and if they're women tight
narrow vaginas the fans yes great
genitals that's very true
so what is this so low meat you eat out
of that if you eat that do you get
$50,000 cuz no you bury him in a fear
factor that's what happens the company
there are EULA like you pay him to eat
that I mean bro I mean what is that
other than a dick but what's with the
folds and the way he touched the flaps
oh okay well that's just that's just one
and it's like steaming you super rabbit
that's just one guy I have many examples
of people eating how did you come across
them I see it all the time on Instagram
food it's recommend me all the time I'm
always like what the [ __ ] God's name
so here's some more of it on Instagram
food I mean Dan what the [ __ ] was going
on
I mean those look like penises I don't
what else well this is just a stack of
[ __ ] question marks oh yeah we need a
translator to tell us what's going on in
the comments
oh well homie here is not imagine the
smell in that room yeah probably smells
bomb cuz there's like a juicy tomato
broth right probably smells great
just gotta close your eyes I mean look
I'm not gonna judge you no it's good
that you're using the whole animal and
all that but you do that anyway
like this [ __ ] all ends up in hotdogs or
whatever in America and they just blend
it up which is fine I just don't eat
that just look at it if you're gonna
blend up like you know people always try
to gross you out about eating chicken
nuggets so like you know there's beak
and eyeball on that I'm like I don't
[ __ ] care if it's blended up and
tastes good I don't give a [ __ ] this I'm
out on
I've never seen that piece that looked
like that before fear factor
well now you've seen people that
actually sell it and here's more I mean
it doesn't stop so here this one is
actually this is all Turkish food by the
way like I was first impressed with like
these [ __ ] know how to cook but
now I got into the weird part of Turkish
food these are balls they even show them
cut them right off the ana and hitting
you know how they make like in pizza
commercials they have like fresh tomato
hitting the counter yeah
that's their version of fresh tomato
crazy right lots of use you know orange
it Oh kabob of testicle damn that's so
gnarly spiced it up and you wouldn't
even know those are testes man that's
true
I wonder if dudes eat that over there
for like you know to get to help their
situation cuz I can China they eat like
do all this crazy [ __ ] yeah they like
killed they straight up like have
extinct extincted like rhinos for their
tusks because these Chinese dudes can't
get it out it's supposed to be
appetizing
yeah that's bomb 400,000 people watched
it this is one I see a lot too and I
don't know what it is this one I see a
lot and part of me thinks that oval it's
like some kind of SH warm oh but I don't
understand what I'm seeing because it
seems somehow attached like it's one
unit right it's not a bunch of Units
like schwarmann it looks you know what
I'm saying like what is this the
consistence is strange too but this this
one tuna or something it's like it's
definitely nice I know I know yeah just
the texture of it looks bizarre but this
this is very popular in Turkey I see
this a lot on my feet
homies getting down with it right now by
mmm so
I'm saying that um my mom never learned
all this amazing right recipe well maybe
she knows this one ela back to the why
were those ones so big by the way these
ones are tiny see that looks like a
penis but the other ones were like mmm
so someone's buying this like their
pastries do you see yeah he's putting
like ten of them in just straight on a
paper like this is a really popular dish
you see how he's just serving it up on a
on a parchment yeah someone eats it in
this one too and I was expecting it to
be kind of chewy but he just crunches
right through it so yeah he's seasoning
it perfectly I mean what does it look
like it's like a long fleshy tube with
flaps Oh
I guess it repeats I mean am i bright
this is fascinating yeah it's weird and
wild oh here you go either I should
excite you I'm telling you it's a
phenomenon do you see how many of these
I found it's the same weird body part do
you guys have any thoughts back there
about what possibly this is I mean maybe
intestines that one looks like yeah like
on these in particular look like
intestines but like this do you want to
eat that I mean isn't it full of [ __ ] I
guess they probably like squeeze it out
first as long as our intestine our case
with that I don't I just dis [ __ ] trips
me the [ __ ] out I don't know what it is
here the homie takes a bite now you can
see like it's like really softer it's
tender last time when we you know the
what's his name cz and the smiley guy
hmm whenever we watch videos of those we
have some Turkish fans right in and give
some context so we'll probably get an
explanation from join if I had an S I
mean I don't know what those flaps are
you think that's like the nutsack it's
like been because it's inside that would
have to be the skin it has to be some
internal organ you know what I'm it's
got to be like bladder or some weird
[ __ ] they wouldn't expect and my humble
opinion as a
connoisseur strange turkish cuisine and
then just to top it off we've got her
voice easy in here there is a class
there is a muted yeah okay here we go
this was making recording it at home oh
no you need the audio [ __ ] yeah he put
in a glug glug sound effect I wanted you
guys to hear it's like not HP pouring
out over that sound what is it I don't
know what it is but I just loved an
ostrich's like the glug glug glug so it
looks kind of gelatinous
and then it goes to no sight no sound it
goes no sound glug
no sir and it's just boring but yeah
sometimes but it's nacho cheese it's
gotta be not you I think there's nacho
cheese in Turkey this guy's not full of
surprises like this guy you see when you
get what you see and say it might have
nacho cheese one thing that kept coming
up on the on the emails from our Turkish
fans is that turkeys they love cheese
that's right all of it I know that about
them mmm okay well there you go
something to get you warmed up everyone
hungry there's a lot of hubbub over the
cats trailer the movie cats based on the
famous play cats I've never seen the
play I really know anything about it
what's all the hubbub why is everyone
crazy about cats the play first of all I
mean I think it's like one of the
longest-running if not the longest
running show on Broadway ever
oh so it's a good play Andrew Lloyd
Webber that's questionable
what's that Zack Andrew Lloyd Webber
wrote a heroic family off
okay so it's um okay so you will you
probably have seen the play cast they've
they have these kind of goofy looking
characters cats the play let me pull up
some images
and I guess what happened is they tried
to convert the look of the place somehow
you have these like humanoid cats dad I
like well it's cool right for a live a
yeah but what they did actually I mean
the movie should have probably just had
them just like this
right that's true that's where they miss
made the first mistake what they did is
I guess they had they CGI'd and tried to
make them look like cats like human
being human cat that are actions that
are cats which is a weird route to go
clearly and so a lot of people have had
an issue with how they look starring a
lot of a lot of superstars the other
Swift is even made an appearance as a
cat and cats one night one chance what
does that mean dan you've seen the play
why is it so at one night one chance I
haven't seen it says I've seen the
trailer and I could tell you it takes
place over more than one night you know
I I did I didn't see it live they made a
like a film of the theatrical version at
some point which I think in like middle
school like a music teacher showed to
the class which big mistake a bunch of
middle school I mean we just made fun of
it the whole time but from what I
remember I mean the plot is really loose
it's just kind of like the cat's a
showcase of all of these different cats
yeah it's one night one chance I went to
go see it oh guy Jack I want to go see
it when I was like four years old and I
left crying because I dared shitless
they are kind of spooky I mean it's
pretty uncanny well and some of the cat
there's like bad cats in it you know
okay
[ __ ] yeah did some scary [ __ ] sake
so here we go a lot of people have been
saying it's like a furry porn which
we'll get into afterwards but one night
oh there's they're like moving like cats
so it's just it's not a human
yeah the I guess the lead the one that
keeps showing is is a famous ballerina
or sometime right it's kind of
interesting how everything is our look
more we go so it's interesting how
everything's just scaled make them look
like tiny little cats - I don't know if
that's in the play but I don't
understand the approach the weave
culminated all the technology and
everything we've come to in filmmaking
and technological advances AI on the
brink and this is the best that we've
we've developed as a human species just
looks bad there's nothing appealing
about it
I don't know why the visually it's like
awful I don't know what is it about a
person looking like a cat
just doesn't work so apparently even the
furries are unhappy with it and you
would think that anyone James Gordon by
the way this sounds like it was recorded
in like 10 Studios removed from sounding
real like the mixing sounds awful right
here we go here we go he's like so far
away from actually feeling like he's in
the screen
[Music]
yeah the badass cat so this cat [ __ ]
[ __ ] up like he's an evil cat or he just
[ __ ] I don't know if he's evil I think
I think he's like a pimp he just [ __ ]
or he's an actual pimp
again it's been a long time since a I
mean it's there's a seedy underbelly to
the cat world that they all live in so -
I can pay to [ __ ] a cat you must do that
oh yeah yeah can I pay to [ __ ] a cat a
cat brothel that's one of the saddest
things about the cab on to go to a cat
he's not changed bond but they want he
there was a whole debate but I mean he's
done a lot he's cut you know yes I mean
he was stringer Bell what do you have
more than that no AJ Idris Elba's is
amazing who even though his name's al oh
[ __ ] Idris Elba's his name's all [ __ ]
what do you want from me what's his name
it it's elbow elbow elbow let's go ahead
down just elbow Edge's elbow yeah that's
the big deal we've got a [ __ ] crazy
name you can't walk around like your
name's Idris Elba and not and expect
people to get it right he's like the
only do with that name in the world
people at home were like you're so
ignorant do you know that like half of
the people from [ __ ] whatever country
the aedra is the most popular name and
elbows the most popular surname shut up
okay I want to see him as James Bond me
too
I think he's fantastic I love him I
would totally love to see him as James
they should just if people care that
much about it just make a new character
called like James block tube literal
[Music]
in Macau [ __ ] Gandalf's in this [ __ ]
Taylor Swift
it looks so down I mean look at this
[ __ ] so oh my god it's like Ghostbusters
level of comedy like the female
Ghostbusters one I hate the way they
look her face don't look
[Music]
kind of makes me want to go see them
play things that I think I'm like test
how am I supposed to like the cat's glad
I even liked cats
well I closed costumes there you show
those look good edges better look at her
face I mean do it my whole you know you
can't have it both ways if you're gonna
CGI a human into a cat you got you can't
have it both ways have them give them a
more cat-like face or put them in a car
at a real costume cuz this is not good
they have a human note they didn't edit
their face at all they have a cue why
didn't you wait at their face you made
the breast of their body look like a cat
but you kept the human nose but even the
body isn't doesn't look like a cat just
looks like I've well it looks you know
what it looks like they're wearing a
suit green Saturday CGI'd in so that
like fur texture yeah right
why it doesn't make sense it's like you
didn't go all the way but her head she's
got the first got the ears but she has
human teeth lips eyeballs and nose and
eyebrows okay what we need an Ethan
Bradberry production here right hit me
with that owl midway to the movie 30
minutes in it with that out should eat
them Bradbury made this her face looks
[ __ ] awful like I don't understand
what I'm look apparently this actress is
black and people were upset that she's a
white cat by the way - why I don't know
it's acting but laughs but look well
also there's no race in an cat at least
not that I'm aware of
I don't know cat culture I don't want to
assume their identity but her face is
slit transplanted on really badly
and then it looks like they changed her
nose I don't understand the whole
argument of like a non gay shouldn't
play a gay character right they're
acting well what isn't that their job
yes Sheila and if you're gonna make a
movie about cats
why are you gonna cast human beings why
not just add a display why don't you
just film a bunch of cats running around
a [ __ ] room
I would watch I would watch the [ __ ] out
of that too big and call it cats movie
oh I agree it's insane it's like um it
should be about cats daily KATV
and a bunch about eating pastrami I'd
start that Scarlett Johansson gotten a
lot of heat first of all she was gonna
play a trans character and then people
like well you have to let a trans person
play it then it's a documentary isn't it
well thank you wisely about I mean if
you really want that level of realism
watch a documentary well the right thing
I don't understand what's the problem
also I think part of the if the if
you're acting a mob what are a serial
killer do you have to have experience
killing people apparently so yeah you're
like bro how many people have you
actually killed in rapes because I'm you
have we have to go to prison and get but
I think part of the actors experience is
you know that level of empathy of being
able to transport their identity into a
body that's not their own mm-hmm they
say Scarlett Johansson can't play a
trans person because she's not trans or
trans person has to play a trans person
to give them the opportunity I mean were
we want the best person for the job
right
are they upset that a trans person
couldn't get a job yes
yeah that's the root of it mm-hmm they
think that oh if you're gonna cast a
trans person there's already not trans
people in movies so why are you hiring a
non trans person right they say there's
a lot of trans actors out there that are
hungry for work and it's like why not
you might say that they're looking for a
transaction
no people got really mad at marlott for
it I don't understand why they're not
just mad at like the casting director
and I like be mad of the production not
not the actor right but but even still
mm-hmm she did drop out by the way well
yeah because everyone like who wants to
do that but even still okay well okay
what do you think about this gila as a
thought experiment your cat a white dude
is cast I don't know if this is the same
but your cast out of your race and then
they make you look like that race you
mean blackface or ooo opposite like a
black dude yeah let's say Wahb well we
well okay
is that the same go ahead you're a white
person can play a blackboard yes I don't
know it but I mean it's a sensitive
topic here so I don't know back in the
day they used to do it like
Shakespearean times they starts to play
women so it's trans the new thing if
you're gonna get trans played trance did
the words that come out of my mouth
makes it yeah what do you think I don't
know it is interesting to think about it
in that context maybe and yeah I mean
there's I mean the white person playing
a black one obviously is very loaded
thing because of the history of
blackface and everything but then maybe
it is the same way what about men
playing women cuz that used to be the
norm right yeah
but in those days women that's why they
used men they didn't let women act right
but so is trans the same because if you
if you change your gender like are we
saying so again this kind of backfires
on them in a sense because these I think
a lot of these people think that gender
is something that is fluid and and a
social construct so if if I you know
look I'm just gonna say this because
it's the easy way to describe it I think
it's finally cut off my dick people get
offended when I say that because they
say just because you cut off your dick
doesn't mean you're not a male anymore
right okay stop I'm just I cut my dick
off and I call myself a woman I
cut it off and identify now as a woman
first of all let's start by saying this
conversation was not planned so we have
no idea what we're talking about
we did not plan to talk about so if we
sound my doing it off probably because
we are stupid but how about my dick okay
you're going okay now I'm gonna wrap a
rubber band around my dick and balls and
tuck it behind my ass and I'm gonna keep
it on there till it falls off rots off
then I'm trans okay no okay and when I'm
trans I'll go and play a trance okay so
actually I'm not I'm just me but the
point is that me without a dick still
looks like me and apparently the gender
is a identity within yourself and has
nothing to do with your genitals so do
you see what I'm saying this is more of
a psychological thing than a physical
thing but I mean I see what you're
saying but I feel like that's not the
best example because people that
actually you know have a sex change they
do a lot more than just remove their
penis they take hormones and I'm over
sip I am oversimplifying for the sake of
brevity and humor and really yeah and I
think you know it all just comes down to
you know equal opportunity more so than
it I think being inherently wrong for an
actor to play something other than
themselves but I that gets lost in it so
where do we draw the line on this what
do you think then I know Dan thinks well
with the I mean I Scarlett said you know
essentially what you were saying is that
I'm an actor this is my job I play other
people and I'm not gonna apologize for
that and you know for her individually I
agree for the studio like again I you
know if people want to be upset about it
I think getting mad at her is misguided
you know it's the studio is deciding
who's gonna be in the movie or not and
so if you feel like they're not giving a
fair shake to trans actors then go after
them or not the person that's just
trying to you know make a living which
sounds weird saying that cuz she's one
of the biggest actresses in the world
but no for her to look the actors are
looking for opportunities to transport
their selves into a new idea like I'm
interesting
Challenge exactly right right - and
there's the added element that she
already got [ __ ] for playing okay how
about this when I've got a dirt I have a
great ghost in a show I have a great one
right ghosts Nichelle's you played a
Japanese character right not Japanese
people gave a [ __ ] I've got a great one
What's Eating Gilbert Grape
Leonardo DiCaprio played a [ __ ] so do
we have to cast a mentally challenged
people to play the role of mentally
challenged people with that Dan go ahead
but do you see that that tiptoes Thank
You Zack yeah tiptoes is a little I
think that and Forrest Gump and I mean
come right Forrest Gump yeah so are you
saying that's a better example they're
both good examples Forrest Gump should
Tom Hanks while Tom Hanks was right
should a slow adult should have played
Tom Hanks should Wendy the slow a dog
have started in Forrest Gump see that
gets that gets really sticky I don't
know because then it comes down to the
capability to write I hate to say it but
I mean you know it's you know if
somebody being able to learn it script
right yeah I mean if somebody is capable
than sure absolutely there you know that
probably would be preferable because it
would add to the authenticity of the
movie right if it really was somebody
with the mental handicap but I mean as
evidenced by Forrest Gump or or Rain Man
or any of these movies you know people
that aren't mentally handicapped can do
a great job portraying it so yeah I mean
so am I just is it just that trans
people should play trans people maybe it
is that's all I honestly don't know I
started the conversation by saying I
don't understand why people are mad but
now I'm starting to understand if you
compare it to black and females I'm
trying to think of there's any other
examples like that I'm trying to put
myself in it so like if someone is gonna
play an Israeli character who's just a
white dude but do that all the time in
movies they're like don't play [ __ ]
Superman that's the ultimate insult
right American hero but like in gangster
movies you always have a tally
playing Jews or Jews playing a town but
you have all the time different
ethnicities playing you have people who
are English playing Americans so Russian
always the bad guys because they are the
bad guys
yes exactly good good job but so as at
the ethnicity become an issue or is it
an issue of opportunity you've got
mm-hmm yeah it's a little sticky it gets
sticky ultimately I just don't think
it's that big of a deal just I don't
know is there I guess it's tough for
trans actors and they're like hey I want
a job right but at the end of the day
stuff for that very end that did
everything is tough look they're trying
to make a big-budget film you need an
actor to pull the audience in okay
Scarlett Johansson people are gonna want
to watch that some unknown trans actor
people are not gonna I mean well maybe
maybe it does happen but I'm saying
that's the if you want you understand
yes power casting you're absolutely
right about that and yes I mean exactly
it comes down to the marketing and they
may draw it for the movie they may be
defeating themselves because maybe this
movie is making this great awareness for
trans community and by having someone
like Scarlett Johansson being
comfortable playing a trans character
and and an in a sympathetic empathetic
role where people are gonna identify
with her or watch this movie and feel
that they're empowering the trans
community by pulling her out they are
doing themselves a disservice because
the less people are gonna watch it and
who knows the movie not even get made
because the studio's got to make money
back at the end of the day mm-hmm I I'm
gonna look it up right now actually in
the case I think the movie so I think
they became victims
it wasn't following the story at all so
I don't really know what is the I think
maybe I think they can't became victims
to their own outrage you know yeah it
looks like the movie is now in limbo so
yeah exactly now because of that it's
not being made at all so you're right
it's a I think what really could make it
or break is it depends on the writing if
the writers like actually consulted with
maybe the real people went to real
experiences
right and they do raise our hands right
I probably probably we got to take a
break right Dan uh yeah we're at yeah
all right
a little after 30 so we didn't actually
finish the cat's thing because actually
the next part of this was that the
reaction of the furries community to the
cat because everyone's like oh they're
the only ones that are happy about this
well no it turns out they're not so
we've got that coming up next as well as
illinit e throwing or cat like a bag of
dirt cat themed yes and then the cat
girl Bella Delphine Belle Delphine cat
girdle we're gonna test her saliva and
Zacks gonna he's gonna drink it so we'll
be right back enjoy the show
welcome everybody to the first annual
Teddy fresh collection hit it it's
summer 2019 and Dan is looking fresh as
it can be with that pink teddy fresh
bucket hat and a lose my number
tee Dan what should they do with your
number lose it that's right Dan thank
you so much all available at Teddy fresh
calm Zac sound lad Zac he's been through
a lot but man he looks good with that
retro lavender t-shirt and black bucket
hat let's see those socks buddy
beautiful very nice look you have
anything to say about for your dating
profile there's like a dating profile
video ok Thank You Zac excellent and
next up we've got Ian the intern head
over to Teddy fresh calm to shop your
summer we're in the interlocking cool as
can be he's moving it he's grooving it
this is not a joke he's earning his keep
this episode is not sponsored so Ian
knows that there's everything at stake
here this shirt and hat bucket hat is
available at Teddy fresh calm and you
have anything to say to the ladies
single ladies no he doesn't thank you in
ela coming up next you know RC o Allah
who made it all possible design his
amazing clothes what's that shirt say
ela
very cool work it girl work it
I don't even need to say anything just
feast your eyes oh I don't think so head
on over to teddy fresh oh you got socks
oh you wearing socks well show them your
shoes anyway because they're fired
that's right folks look at those shoes
they're not Teddy fresh so don't buy
those but everything else dubai
excellent you look beautiful and
credible dan dan is back a wardrobe
change WoW is that a grayscale button-up
working it black bucket hat I cannot get
over this outfit let me see those socks
Dan holy [ __ ] Teddy fresh are you
freaking kidding me whoa don't show much
too much leg here now people we're
trying to do a safe for work show here
Dan haha alright and finally finally the
host of the show
ethan klein Deb and I forgot the word
for the inspiration there's the muse of
30 fresh ethan klein plus-size model
because we are very progressive we don't
discriminate Ethan likes to wear
extra-large and he's rocking it he wears
the socks which slides good she slides
buddy got them on sale we like sales and
it talks a button-up shirt and shorts I
don't know about that now very much into
that look okay cut it up cut it up and
commercial is over back to the show
how was the teddy fresh fashion show did
you guys watch it Dan not obviously the
audience watched it I thought it was
cool
so mom Army's make sure to support your
teddy fresh calm already Ethan weird to
watch the [ __ ] out so we were so here
let's look at it how about the first
thought about the cats so like you were
saying everyone was thinking well
furries would like that movie so the
furries BuzzFeed on did some
hard-hitting journalism FY even furries
think the catch trailer looks bad they
quote a furry who says furries wants
something they can [ __ ] FAP to and the
cats movie is not that one furry said
say I have a feeling this guy probably
doesn't represent the furry community
I love the brutal honesty yeah because
well that's what I always figured that
this was a deeply sexual thing but
whenever I ask them they're like no come
on it's got to be well here it goes on
it explains a little bit the furry
fetish contrary to some people's
assumptions even members of the furry
community think the catch trailer looks
weird sorry Taylor Swift when the catch
trailer hit the internet earlier this
week the reaction was pretty on and that
unanimous oh why am i coming abhor and
disgust at the CGI fur technology mixed
with eerie human faces it also led to a
pretty widespread joke online the first
must love the human cat mashup
but according to interviews with members
of the furry community that's not true a
furry from Canada whose first SONA a
term fur is used for their animal
alter-ego is a lemur told BuzzFeed news
the filmmaker didn't get the human cat
mix right
he said furries wants something that can
[ __ ] fav - and the cat's movie is not
that the ballet aspects are display of
human beauty and movement in form if the
CG if you see G that it'll be trashy
also cats is not particularly
comfortable watch to begin with it's
meant to be like well cats so he's
saying that the ballet is an aspect of
human beauty and what they're looking
for is animal beauty and that makes it
sound [ __ ] creepy yes Oh animal the
disconnect according to members of the
furry fandom is that they are drawn to a
very specific cartoony ass aesthetic so
while yes the CGI cat people are from
cats are human-animal hybrids they don't
feature that thing's furries are drawn
to like big eyes expressive faces and
cute proportions the cat's cats just
look like cat people so there you go
even the furries are not a lot but I
guarantee you little cartoons great you
know how when when this reminds me of
Avatar when the blue aliens came out I
first of all every time I realized that
avatar was the highest-grossing film
that was just passed by and game it
blows my mind because that movie [ __ ]
sucks I hate it it's dumb why is it so
bad couldn't wait for it to be over but
what I what I think is that this movie's
gonna spawn probably a new fetish
because now after avatar you see these
blue people or I saw I seen a dude who
tattooed his whole [ __ ] body blue so
he could [ __ ] like a avatar we look at
on the show yeah and so I think this is
gonna spawn a new a new movement I think
you can see a lot of cats porn after
this movie comes out so buckle up for
that oh boy the responses i've seen
within the community have been either
people getting really frustrated with it
for fun to get completely laughable some
find it funny that this is what
hollywood thinks is marketable when it
comes to selling furry content to a
general audience i don't think that is
something they considered dude while
others are infuriated that this is how
anthropomorphic characters were chosen
to appear design wise the the furry
community is upset what is a picture at
the top is that like an edited version
to make it look yeah this
is what they're saying like if you
wanted to make a look more cat-like or
maybe furries more like furries could
masturbate to it then but I do agree
like you should have I mean come on this
just looks stupid
it looks so dumb I don't think the one
on the left it's not right it's not
better it's it's it's probably worse
it's actually probably worse I can't
jerk off to this this I can almost get
to because like it looks more female but
this on nobody's masturbating to this I
guarantee you that well eventually
people will masturbate to all of this as
we've learned in the internet there's
always a way right Ian right no comment
right so there you go the cat's movie is
a disappointment to all doesn't come out
until the end of the year so maybe
they'll pull of Sonic and sanic sanic
and redo it or I'd really doubt it
that's not one character that's like the
whole [ __ ] movie yeah speaking of
cats this is the big gossip story on the
Internet of last week illinit II who is
a twitch streamer with big-ass titties
she's like a titty streamer well I don't
know the size of her tits I'm only
saying that she's known for wearing like
very little clothing and it's us and I
think it's well assumed that most people
are watching this because she's a pretty
girl that doesn't wear a lot of clothes
is that right Dan I everything I've ever
seen of her she doesn't actually wear
that revealing clothes it's not like the
ones that just wear like bikini tops or
stuff like that
she wears I mean cleavage Laurel yes she
she dresses in a relatively revealing
way yes yeah I mean yes thank you Dan
thank you and I'm just doing a google
search it's not that bad
let me see yeah I really it's just
showing some cleavage well there's some
yeah I guess that's it I mean look I'm
not a man it's not that revealing it's
not even like anything I mean if I saw
someone like that on the street I
wouldn't feel like you wouldn't think
about it twice I think about it more
than
twice do you know I'm kidding no
laughter huh tap dance went in here okay
look at her course not okay
well at any rate it there I think but
there's a term that people have and I'm
not necessarily agreeing our disagree my
only trying to explain the perspective
of the people who who dislike her they
call her a titty streamer and I guess
she's done stuff where like she flips up
her skirt shows her thong I don't know
okay okay I'm not gonna blame the girl
for being attractive and being on Twitch
okay but what happened was that first
PETA tweeted out this video calling on
twitch to take a stand for cats and
removal entity from twitch immediately
she's using the platform to post animal
abuse which sends a dangerous message to
anyone watching her videos cats are not
props to abuse for views well let's
watch the clip when we got here I mean
yeah what do you think about her outfit
here I mean it's I would see people
wearing that every day but yeah I mean
it's just a little sloppy for the kid it
increases our views yeah not my taste
but obviously a lot of women do dress
like that too yeah who aren't actually
trim just who are just walking down the
street right which also incidentally
increases the views but they you know
anyway the cat walks up the twitter is
[ __ ] dude I don't know what to say cuz
everytime I fullscreen it breaks been
doing this for a while
i lo so the cat walks in the way she
scoops it up and throws it behind her
and so I mean I never had a cat weight
like weights right oh I would never do
that but no I know that cats are
different right they yes sir very nimble
I don't know if there's a something
behind her - maybe there's a bed but I
mean clearly clearly Shh I don't know
I'm just not I guess I'm not that
offended by it I I've had cats before
they're very you can [ __ ] throw the
hell out of cats
yeah I've had cats all my life I don't
find this to really be that
reprehensible it's I wouldn't really
think about it twice okay well the cat's
fine he PETA cherry-picked it and now I
guess people already hate her because
she gotten some beef with PewDiePie
where she claimed one of his videos he
did like an eye tracking video where he
you can track where the pupils are
looking and he was looking at twitch
girls and he kept looking at her tits he
couldn't help himself
whatever that was oblong plotting a
video and then I guess she got upset
because of something he said and she
said I'm gonna claim his video believe
she was upset because he referred to her
as a twitch thought yeah the other term
which I suppose it's pretty derogatory
it's like calling her a [ __ ]
I mean thought is that hoe over there so
it's just calling her hoe basically yeah
and so she got upset claimed this video
which is wrong obviously like I mean I
don't [ __ ] with well you don't do that
at this Pyatt yeah and I don't [ __ ]
first of all with you know it's funny
her admitting that is the crazy thing
about copyright laws that you have to be
able to prove that it was made in bad
faith so her admitting that on camera is
like the impossible proof that she did
it in bad faith so it seems like she's
got an anger problem or something this
girl is like I don't know to go out of
your way and claim PewDiePie's video is
just it's so stupid so immature and
throwing the cat she's she's obviously
just really immature
you know I don't know I
the thing is like it doesn't sound like
what he did was that offensive so just
just go with it if I was her
yeah embrace it yeah well if somebody
called you a ho well if I dressed like
that I'm not I'm not calling her a ho
but I would at least understand we're
certainly not the first time you know I
can understand it yeah well I mean when
you dress like it you kind of ask for
that attention you know you know okay I
think that's why I don't like dressing
like that fair enough
I don't like getting that attention and
so I mean she could have said hey [ __ ]
you dude you know Pig or whatever but
claiming his video boss is illegal and a
big no-no where I come from so that's
why people hate her
so then PETA cherry-picked this and now
all the kids on the internet are saying
you know we got to we got to ban illinit
e because of animal abuse and I don't
know I just I don't find it that
offensive I'm sorry I know people are
gonna hate are gonna people are not
gonna like hearing me say that because
the hive mind wants to burn her alive
for animal cruelty but guys you're
you're you're siding with PETA okay PETA
is basically saying sure I'll take that
cat and euthanize it people are calling
animal protective services literally she
has a bunch of tweets withdrawal re
later people were calling animal
protective services to come inspect her
home and make sure she wasn't abusing
her animals well they basically you
really think that this cat you're
looking out for the interests of this
cat you think this cat's gonna be
happier and a pound or being euthanized
instead of a home with her I mean just
because she tossed it behind doesn't
mean she doesn't love and take care of
the cat that has me [ __ ] if it gets if
it gets taken to the pound you know so
as usual the kids take it too far I
don't know I'm not offended by this
now what another video that somewhat
pulled and Dan you you kind of spoke
more to this one here she is giving
vodka to her cat
and I guess well here let's let's let's
watch and then comment on it for the
kids
can you not play copyrighted music what
is with these people on Twitch
well how they don't care about the vods
I'm just over it
well I don't need sound do I know twitch
is such a nightmare everything about
tonight I wouldn't go on that website
I'll just all you guys are like okay
YouTube had a lot of drama but I'm now
learning that's which is it's like which
is way more talk around my city and to
twitch is so toxic and crazy yeah
and everybody listens to [ __ ]
copyrighted music so I got a muted which
sucks but she goes for the cat she has
[ __ ] in her mouth and the cat looks
inside her mouth thinking its water I
guess but the cat was who that cat was
like used to drinking out of her mouth
was that a kiss yeah I've never I mean
is that normal that cat will kiss your
mouth like that yeah yeah but shudders a
dog cats are different normal reaction
for the cat yeah I find this one to be
way worse than the other definitely
tasted it and oh this pad is like the
reaction the cat like panics like oh my
god the cat is really really really
spooked by that and she's laughing I
actually feel bad for the cat that was
yeah that was the cat was really like if
shredder reacted something like that I
feel awful you have you worried about
him and Dan you had pointed out that
alcohol is very poisonous to cats yeah
in particular extremely like a very
small amount can be deadly
I mean a tiny little bit right but yeah
it's the fact that they're little but
also just their bodies can't process
alcohol at all and I looked it up at
like a teaspoon worth of alcohol can be
fatal to a cat so that is [ __ ] out
this one is way worse than yeah this
seems really cruel on the way she
laughed and Lily for sure I would have
felt really bad I mean clearly that the
cat didn't get a lot of alcohol just
tasted it and then recoiled but but he
didn't taste it you can see oh ya know
the catcher panics I mean really panics
and if I don't know I if I
that's like harming your animal
intentionally and yeah I just imagine
putting her do that and seeing him react
I would just feel awful so I don't know
you know this I don't like to see but
it's twitch everybody on twitch is a
[ __ ] idiot psycho like I don't know
you know what I'm saying I mean yeah
it's bad I don't like it but everybody
on twitch is a psych Chris Brown is a
trendy so let me see what else I got
here
it's a whole thing so she tweeted out
hey guys I understand the concern I'm
sorry for my lapse in judgment I
shouldn't have gotten frustrated with
Milo but I dropped him on the floor
behind my chair oh so there isn't a bet
she dropped him on the floor not that's
strong the vodka thing was well over a
year ago but it was also a stupid thing
to do
also I understand the desire to report
me to pet authorities encourage everyone
to do so if the field pets are being
mistreated by anyone anywhere my animals
are well loved and living a warm and
caring home and I will comply with any
authorities that seek to validate this
please stop coming to my house and ask
my neighbors where I am it's actually
really scary people have been sharing
this message from her discord that is
yet honking firmed it says don't worry
guys I'm fine I spoke to someone at
twitch today and I'm not banned but
people who have been harassing me might
be I don't okay I mean I don't have our
time believing that's real yeah but
what's the big deal well it's just it
anytime anybody shows a cropped image of
something from discord I am extremely
skeptical it is unbelievably easy to
fake stuff on discord it's the simplest
thing ever but the message I don't feel
is damning is it
well she's implying that she's got
contacts on the inside that or he does I
well I'm sure she does but I don't think
she would share that publicly you know
what I mean so maybe I'll say this for
my own experience on Twitch
I'll give you example that the second
part of this is that people are also
upset about Twitch's double standard on
forcing things so I'll tell you that my
experience because we used to be on
tuition we need to be partner with them
when we did our charity stream Joey
salads came here and he so he went down
to the park across the street and Justin
roiland pepper sprayed him in the face
for charity of course and we had to do
it in a way because we weren't ready for
it the Joey live streamed it on his
phone and then we watched it on the TV
mm-hmm so twitch suspended Joey's twitch
account like immediately but they didn't
they didn't do anything to us and I
later spoke on the phone it's my contact
there and he said and I quote that we
give special treatment who are to our
partners to our big partners well we
take care you because I was I was joking
with him like isn't that funny isn't
that hilarious that Joey got banned and
we didn't this is [ __ ] we showed the
same thing in fact we put him out there
we told him to do it
I mean effectively it was us not him
they banned him and didn't punish us and
we joked about it and I joked about it
with the twitch staff and he said yeah
we could Lou yeah yes you get special
treatment because you're a big partner
of ours but is that really surprising I
mean uh of course not not really yeah
it's obvious that I mean I get a way low
higher level of service from YouTube
then right then when I was a small
Channel makes sense right it does it's
funny I was just listening to the
Bilborough
podcast recently and he was talking
about Epstein mhm
and so he was saying he was saying the
same thing that you're saying like are
you surprised that someone who's higher
up gets a special treatment like if he
was given like a simple example if you
go to a a club and there's the the guy
at the entrance who lets people in
what's the bouncer the bouncer so if you
go to a club and there's a line to get
in but you know the buns the bouncer the
bouncer is gonna let you in because he
knows you and he said that goes home
life all the way up so if you know
someone
and we're really high up you're gonna
get special treatment right yeah that
makes sense
people always look at it's like some
nefarious conspiracy but the truth is
it's just when you know someone you
treat them kinder than if you did it you
have more empathy because you know them
personally mm-hmm well having empathy
for child rapist is one thing well I
would go further and say if it's
somebody that you know that makes your
company a lot of money right you get
preferential treatment but really what
it's all about yeah thank you
so apparently illinit E is very popular
I don't know how she's very popular in
twitch right Dan
yeah from what I understand she's it's
like her him one other girl whose name I
can never was that one girl she's more
in pokey Maine is really big
oh she's big - that's true in the same
stratosphere can I like Pokemon see I
don't know if it's the same stratosphere
because she's a female but I don't know
if she's like a cleavage streamer I
think I think she escapes yeah she's not
I don't want to know again every buck
this whole class warfare on Twitch and
I'm not familiar with it so I don't I
don't want to lump anyway yes so but
what they're saying is that there's a
double standard for example here's a
video of a user named only use me blade
who threw his dog similar to how she
threw her cat and he was promptly
permanently banned this one has licensed
music - okay thank you for that sup here
we have the video so remotely men
permanently banned I mean this this
video is [ __ ] insane
honestly this guy's it's the weirdest
thing and all of his friends are like
bro what did you just do
I guess they're drunk and streaming
there's two angles which I'll show you
the first one looks way worse the second
one doesn't look as bad but he's hanging
out with his dog and he just [ __ ]
Chuck's him like and all this ruins are
like why the [ __ ] was that but he
doesn't get it he doesn't understand why
you can't chuck your dog he's like no no
no I always Chuck my dog they're so
trashed
it's just good offering I can't stand
that this is to Alice no I mean that
people will treat their animals like
that where's the one of the second angle
I can't like if I if I think that
shredder is in the slightest pain oh
well yeah I mean shredders our babe he's
our child he's our firstborn child here
just from the second angle here doesn't
look as bad here but I mean he Chuck the
dog actually helped landed quite elegant
that's true doesn't look as bad here I
still went under that but yeah why would
you just chuck your dog that doesn't
make any sense yeah but it's pretty
funny how all of his friends are like
well what was not yeah and they're all
pissed drunk too so having the presence
of mind when you're that drunk to be
like what was that anyway that guy got
immediately permanently banned so huh
it's quite similar to only just a few
months ago I believe - really oh yeah
this is amazing history and so illinit
II wasn't punished at all she didn't get
a suspension not even for a day so it
seems like even if you're gonna give
someone a special treatment
that it's a stretch here - not even
punished or anything yeah in fact they
haven't even acknowledged it is that
right damn as far as I've been able to
see um there may have been an update
this morning that I haven't seen yet but
um yeah I she seems to be getting away
with it I mean the vodka one for sure at
least deserves like a short suspension
maybe not a band but yeah it's way worse
and it's weird how that one not to say
that it hasn't gotten attention it is
but everybody's mostly focusing on the
cat tossing and I think people are
casting maybe focusing on the cat
tossing because it's such a parallel and
people are I think they're just trying
to prove that's which has a double
standard and they want to know why right
so she got a pass and frankly I have to
say they have a point there was a twitch
streamer this one's so crazy it's not
really related but it blew my mind I'm
not gonna show it whether there was a
female streamer
who during a live stream would choke her
[ __ ] cats out
to be open group that um yeah they
wouldn't pass out but she would like
like squeeze him really hard and they
would start clawing her until she bled
and they'd jump away she was doing it to
show them who's boss
so she could be the Alpha the part that
blew me oh god so but she was banned for
a year I don't know how big she was
obviously that's way worse that's like
psycho
she'd be banned for life banned first
sector so you know I don't know so pure
and sweet yeah they are there dude why
would you want to and why would you even
have that urge to do anything that's
fine a weird but I've I've heard well
you just I think someone who harms
animals is uh it's as you about I mean I
don't know it's uh self-hate violent
tendencies I mean not a healthy person
yeah although I can't say that these
people are I think these people are just
doing stupid things I'm not saying that
like the two clips that we saw I don't
necessarily think they're animal abusers
well that second guy makes me wonder the
way I know that probably just did
something lupa taken care of
yeah yeah yeah like I'm sure al inity
takes great care of her cats and she the
cats like that cat looked like good I
mean do you agree with that Dan as a cat
person
I mean the fact in the vodka clip that
the cat is comfortable enough to come up
in nuzzle or her mouth or whatever I
mean yeah I mean obviously this class
like her yeah but I mean that's why that
one's [ __ ] up and said why do that to
this right you mean yeah the cats trust
exactly yeah but ultimately she's just
she's done a very stupid thing and we
all do stupid things though only
happened that she was a live streaming
it right and sure life shouldn't be
ruined her career shouldn't be ended but
I think it's fair to expect at least a
little bit of I was expecting this guy
who was banned for life for something
that's like it's really our
again he needs to be bent for life yeah
I don't know if he had a previous
history but like obviously his seemed
more little more intense but you can't
really draw a distinction between the
two so the fact that he was banned for
life and she wasn't punished at all is
very very questionable for sure so there
you go I think I think people are are
definitely overreacting but I also do
acknowledge that tuition absolutely has
a double standard there's been stuff of
like dudes being banned for being
topless and then girls with like I don't
know there's a lot of stuff around
sexuality girls who push the envelope
obviously much farther than her who are
punished but then like a dude shows
himself topless like apparently dudes
can't even talk be topless on boys know
why I think they may have revised that
when I was when I was researching this
that was like an issue a couple years
ago but they've now revised their rules
I think they're because I don't know I
torches a nightmare it does there's a
nightmare and I do feel like the people
that run Twitch there's been like rumors
that'll entities like sweeping sleeping
with twitch staff and I have no freaking
idea if that's true or not it sounds
outlandish but what I'm saying is of I'm
not saying anything about her but the
people that run to which would do that
that I know of like I wouldn't be
surprised at all like they have these
parties I wouldn't be surprised they're
just a bunch of young kids these are not
kids it's which is not like a slick
company it's not it's just a bunch of
kids and it's owned by Amazon they have
a ton of money and it's like you can't
tell from our experience it's definitely
just a completely different age
demographic like compared to YouTube the
people that we work with on YouTube are
two adult professional their parents
they whatever the people who were really
violent which are like it's a great age
or younger it's a bunch of kids that are
running twitch and they have parties
they mingle with the the streamers like
there was this twitch party we went to
once
turn a3 and all the streamers were there
and all the staff was there and
everyone's getting drunk together same
age you know those you know they're
[ __ ] yeah and I wouldn't even such a
drunk 20-somethings decks I don't and I
wouldn't even be surprised if some of
these girls are like I'm going to
specifically try to [ __ ] at a high level
twitch staffer to get preferential
treatment you know if I have tits I'd
[ __ ] they should have but again so and
another aspect that I want to address in
conclusion is that there's a lot of
angry young men I want to clear this up
who seek attractive girls on Twitch and
they perceive them as having no skill or
no talent yet they are very popular and
that makes them angry because they want
to be very popular on Twitch and they
see themselves on better at this game
I'm more entertaining than her yet
nobody watches me and they say they get
angry because the girl just has a pair
of tits and she's attractive and I say
to them you in this world first of all
you need to get a [ __ ] grip dude you
and this world have got to use what
you've got some people are really good
at video games ninja by far the most
popular
some people have big titties but that
alone will not take you that far you
gotta have some talent you gotta be able
to entertain something Marth
well I don't know let me amend or I
probably would bet that there are a lot
of attractive girls that wouldn't make
it because I don't know not as big as
her but I feel like well yeah you're
right to be successful in any career
people always you have don't be it
doesn't just happen for no reason you
have to be hard-working or you know
there has to be a lot to the sauce of
what makes it happen you're right it's
not just boobs
you're or juice you're absolutely right
when people are successful in any field
it's easy to discount their success and
say oh they're only there's only that
people only succeed especially over the
long term by being extremely motivated
and working hard and being and having an
edge and being very good
that hedge so maybe she's got a lot
maybe you're really talented and you've
got all the same things as her but she's
got an edge she's attractive girl in
that and that matters in this world to
some people
she's clearly delivering some unique
product that is is that people want to
consume and just because you're a pasty
ugly [ __ ] guy who happens to be
poured mediocre at fortnight you know
you don't have to it's sorry dude that's
life
what it's always been like that men get
preference handsome men you know get
preferential treatment you think I
wouldn't like to be beautiful it's kind
of interesting too if you look at the
top streamers on Twitch like the male's
I mean granted they are you know people
like ninja are excellent at what they do
but it is interesting I mean the
majority of them are pretty handsome
guys too
I mean it is not an ugly dude you know
what I mean and it's like I'm it's not
fair but that's why I know yeah
attractive people get ahead in life
that's reality
man or woman I absolutely agree and I
mean sex sells that's like true to every
degree so I think there's a lot of young
men that hate these attractive girls who
show their cleavage on Twitch because
they see them as having this unfair
advantage but look that's life dude you
gotta find another edge I feel like
those guys are probably the kind of guys
that would watch it of course that's
exactly right no they're the ones that
are watching they're the ones that are
supporting and subscribing exactly who's
watching her that's so true
somebody is watching her subscribing
supporting her donating you know what
I'm saying I don't know I said though
the amount of hate that attractive girls
on Twitch get makes me uncomfortable
it's like there it's just yeah you got
to get real dude you know if you can get
better than ninja fortnight then great
if they're able to get the following and
pull in the views then they're doing
something right
that demand will always be there look
you know some people want to watch for
and I with some titties and that's just
that right ela that's right thank you
did I cover everything I feel like I did
but with the Elana T drama yeah I mean
that that's all there really is to it I
mean the backlash seems to be continuing
and you know people claiming well
they're supposedly like Ethan kind of
mentioned in passing evidence of her
having some dirt on which staffers or
whatever but nothing's materialized from
that so it's it's um it's very
unsubstantiated rumors yeah and rumors
by the way that I would totally see
someone making up and everyone just
gobbling up because they want to believe
it yeah I mean as far as I know the only
evidence is again that discord
screenshot which is a crop screenshot
that's not evidence I mean yeah it's
nothing nothing
I didn't I could have said the same
thing about like well all she said is
that I talked to twitch and that they're
not gonna punish me assume that's not
weary you 'z the score for the show and
when even ten seconds I could change my
profile picture to her and my name to
illinit II and it would be like I'm her
but if it was it does right it's not
that big of a deal I mean she says let's
assume it's real she says I talk at
which she's not gonna punish me okay
we've proven there's a double standard
she has context at which so did I when I
was on twitch and then she says but
they're gonna punish the people who are
asking me well I am ayat I don't know
who I guess she's talking about others
twitch streamers as far as we've seen
that hasn't happened otherwise I'm sure
it would have been brought up so who
knows well the bigger twitch is gonna
get they're gonna have a lot more thanks
to to deal with like the double standard
or I don't see it I don't think twitch
is going gonna get big for a minute I
thought it was when like ninja was
coming up and we were on there with our
podcast but I'll tell you they were
trying so hard to be more than video
games mm-hmm and it was so important for
them to grow as a platform yeah and I
think then bringing our podcast on was
really smart and we had a lot of success
there but one tank came time to
renegotiate our contract they were
penny-pinching us and throwing us away
and have
totally unreasonable demands and we're
even I would even go as far as to say
vindictive and petty when we decided to
leave twitch and go back to YouTube
like for example after the after I
decided that they cancelled my
partnership like just had a spite I
already had before the pod color years
yeah and I would stream on and off and
after that it ended they canceled my day
one other way and canceled my
partnership to get rid of my subscribe
button and then they still owed me money
at 6 months later after trying to chase
down my payment for so long they're like
oh so we're trying to pay you but we
actually need you to sign up for the
partner program again before we can pay
you I was like you [ __ ] clowns
I refused I actually got in on and off
with them for a long time and I just
flat out said I am NOT enrolling in that
[ __ ] here's my wire information you put
me out [ __ ] pay me you know so I
think that the management there's a mess
I think that they're extremely
short-sighted with their budget and how
and how they cater to content and they
lost us big-time I liked being there but
they lost us big time I think that the
management is really bad I think they
don't have good people there and I think
that they they're just too invested in
video games and they haven't
successfully branched out to other
verticals yeah I mean they were trying
to get us to like agree on amount of
hours to stream they're like how can you
stream more hours but I'd say the show
is the show it's not about how many
hours we can go exactly the show is
about what we talked about and it has
its own like it or leave it
yeah we're not gonna stream longer to
meet some our quota no we just want the
show to be good hmm but I don't think
twitch is ever gonna I think they're I
don't see it I don't see it they they're
not able to cater to high quality people
like playing video games is cool and
that's one thing
but if you want like talented people
making high quality content there
there's no [ __ ] reason to do it
another game is not that's what I mean
it's not but it's not that what they're
doing isn't great it's great on Twitch
and it's obviously really entertain cuz
a lot of people are watching it but if
you want to if you have their vertical
ya broader than video games then you
need to I don't know they just weren't
willing to do what it took to to do it
and so I don't it you know they want to
ask me that like took us out to a fancy
dinner and they're trying to pick our
brain and he's like what do you think
you know how do we compete and I was
like oh well you need votes you need to
and this was during a time when people
were really angry with YouTube and all
their systems and ad pocalypse and
copyright and all this I was like bro
everybody's trying to make a competitor
to YouTube
there's creators who are banding
together try to make competitors of
YouTube you guys have the money and the
means in the audience just start making
vods and recommending bots to people
because they have vods of streams but
there's no curated there's people don't
upload their videos like even if you
allowed youtubers like me or any of
their big creators who stream their to
just upload their YouTube videos also on
Twitch and then created some means of
delivering it and compensating you in a
couple years time would already start
building that ecosystem and they're like
oh we never even thought about that it's
so crazy
just think about I mean how have a
market it is on YouTube of like
reuploads and edits of twitch streams
like that's you that's such a good point
like why is that even our highlight
channel started right well we take our
clips to the point that like twitch
can't even manage their own content that
originates there that people would
rather watch it on YouTube because
YouTube system of serving it and
curating it is so much better
mmm-hmm that's a huge problem like if
they they need to develop a way to
curate content and serve it to people if
you show down on people's home page
they'd be watching videos on Twitch
before you know it mm-hmm and then all
the sudden people are spending more time
on twitch because one of the inherent
issues with twitch is that you can only
watch one video at a time
one stream once persons streaming you
want watching live is way better than
the vaad mm-hmm let's face it because
you want to interact what's happening
right so I think part of the issue on
Twitch they love people have trouble
with is that you you could only watch
one live show at once so it's like right
competing yeah you can watch a thousand
videos and there's there's space for
everybody on YouTube but on Twitch
you're actually competing for the live
view that's why it's so toxic I think so
between the streamers yeah and I think
that's I think so because people see
these like titty streamers as stealing
views because again people decide what
they want to view it's just a stupid
nonsense but I was I was blown away by
twitch is uh almost how they brushed
aside what I thought was good yeah to
them and when he was like oh we hadn't
even considered that I was like are you
[ __ ] yeah that's well sure you should
worry especially like you said I mean
this was during the period of that puck
like when yes wait for YouTube was at
its highest like that was the time the
strike right then and they were just
dropping all completely it's crazy with
Jeff Bezos money you you would think
that yeah
but they are such penny-pinching little
Fox over there and they're just so
they're so focused on the bottom line
I think twitch probably just loses a
bunch of money and Amazon well that's
true but I think Google is way clearly
but I mean YouTube is like though I
advertising arm the YouTube is a special
I think they they understood the value
there but I don't think Amazon is stands
a valiant which for the potential they
bought it I don't know what's wrong I
don't know somebody they can't figure it
out over there anyway [ __ ] it all
[ __ ] [ __ ] twitch I'm over them I
really am you know I were like being
there but they blew it and this kind of
[ __ ] is stupid because
on YouTube there's such a clear
separation of the staff and I think
that's part of the problem also the
people feel somewhat alienated on
YouTube but on Twitch there's not enough
bigger separation because while I
wouldn't be surprised at all if it was a
rumor that ill entity sleeping with
twitch staff you have the hand I
wouldn't all be surprised because it's
extremely possible for something like
that to happen
that's my schpeel and in short what do
we say in the last episode thank you to
buzz thank you to BuzzFeed people of
like I'm sorry no TMZ thank you to TMZ
for saving you Zach I want to talk to
you about something I advise fate okay
I'm talking about BuzzFeed Zach his dad
is a realtor and he's been showing us
some houses you know we talked about an
anecdote with our Realtors and it was
funny because we're like man I hope both
of them don't listen and what ended up
happening is that both of them listened
and they teamed up and now they're both
representing us because I brought in
Zach's dad after the fact yeah and so we
looked we went to go look at the house
over the over the past couple days and
now we're show up to the house and it's
all three of them all three of them came
reality reality Wars yeah but I was like
I saw the I saw all three of the people
Zach's mom Zach sat in our old realtor
and we pull up and I was like ela this
is so [ __ ] weird that we are we were
hoping that none of them listened and
then they're all there and they all
heard it
they've all heard it and I was just it
was just so weird when your dad's funny
Zach he pulled up um and he was all
tucked in yeah I call it a Todd and tuck
is that time is hot he's got a bit of
he's got a bit of he's got a chub and
tuck well you know I told him about the
chap and talking but he had it like the
high you know he's got the muffin top
he's a bit of a muffin top cuz he's a
tall guy
it was all tucked in he was tucked in
like pretty high like this
yeah something like that yeah my name's
Todd sy said Elissa Todd and tuck Donny
pretty fine I'm gonna start using that
but your dad's fine man cuz we've been
talking about the property and all this
and I says your dad sends me this
unprompted Zack he says that's real
father with a picture of you and Ron
Jeremy yeah now that implies that your
mom [ __ ] Ron Jerry sure and got
pregnant well it's just totally I'm
prompted and I was like andddd but
that's my daddy sends random [ __ ] well
then here's another one you tell me what
you think about this he sent me this
unprompted I said Wow he says such a
nice night I says looks huge the pool he
says that's what Zach's mom said what do
you think about that you know he makes
these jokes like that are just so
inappropriate he's like pulls the best
Larry David moment you like it sounds
like you like your dad yeah I love my
dad oh that's good yeah but that's
beautiful then yeah I was expecting
almost for you to just be like I'm so
embarrassed it does this [ __ ] I'm like
you know I don't want to even I don't
even want to know you live it we have
the same sense of humor and like we feed
off of that
okay that's awesome that's beautiful
then yeah cuz my dad or your dad said
that you used to sleep in a bed next to
their bed okay there's a few things I
need to clarify and he said he said used
to slip on the floor like a dog and he's
put step on you there's a few things I
need to clarify alright one I did not
show you guys that I I wanted to help
you guys you guys are the godparents
Ethan you're the god papa
they do not get compensated I did not
get comments cuz your dad said
he said that he would well he said that
you only to honey yes so exactly for
honest with us no no Zach percent honest
and don't feel bad because I like your
daddy's a great agent and I'm glad we're
connected with him but be honest were
you compensated in in money or in any
other way
advantage is that forgiveness yeah I
have to pay him a certain amount of
month okay this month taken off the bill
sounds like payment that sounds like a
fine I did not receive $200 got a
commission bro your Bill got prorated
how much money did he take off the bill
$200 your dad makes him you pay him $200
a month sometimes sometimes and I accept
when you could when you Commission your
anyways my point was why does he make
you pay $200 a month well now that I'm
rent 21 and you know out there in the
world is a bum yeah that's a pretty good
deal on rent yeah to be honest so
anyways I wanted to help you guys out
because I never would want to go against
the family so I wanted you to be taken
care of and you were talking to certain
area and you know that that's my dad's
specialty so that's why well I tell you
that I appreciate that because he's very
good and I'm glad we got connected with
him yeah you have you have see the way
he your mom told me it though is that
you guys were arguing about it and your
mom was like I wanted to respect your
privacy he didn't want to give you his
information and your dad squeezed it out
of you because he wanted it he you know
he wanted to he wanted to sell us a
house and then he gave you that $200
Commission I mean I was reluctant at
first because obviously I want to keep
you know I don't want your stuff getting
out there but look I realized that this
could help you right of course
absolutely so yeah and then yeah now is
it true that you had a pacifier ceremony
it was somewhat of a ceremony yes but
there was no fire involved
okay what was the ceremony do remember
it so I I did have a pacifier till I was
like four years old
mm-hmm and they made me get rid of it
and I'm still sad but this day it was
5:00 on Tuesday
same four years old now five years old
before okay I mean I I don't have much
of a beef really no I like your dad your
dad's awesome dude yeah bombed the
toddster he's like they he my parents
love you guys your dad so funny he walks
in Alice he's like he's just got this
thing about him he's like so I know the
builders the builders make great
material I've seen my dad walk in the
houses and he'll go right for the fridge
first and like make like a grilled
cheese or something no he didn't do that
but he [ __ ] well I know there's
nothing I know he inspected this [ __ ]
out of this house he toured apartment I
mean a great way so much so that I think
he talked us out of it which is good I
want someone who's willing to get you
out of a place right he's got the balls
to do it so yeah you talked me out of a
place I'm gonna want you on my next spot
mmm-hmm so I think your dad got me yeah
the toddster got me so is ron jeremy
your dad I hope so okay yeah your
parents were great I don't want them to
get the wrong idea and they're fantastic
I got a trim I got a trim trim they made
it sound like you were gonna come in
when like the buzz got a haircut and I
did the other thing was I did break up
with my girlfriend so yeah they won't
give you a hard time but yeah how you
doing I'm okay who broke it up I did you
broke it off how come um just a lot of
things that just I don't know I'm too
young to be in that series of a
relationship you don't be tied down yeah
and you know interesting you got a whiff
of that Submit yeah it was it didn't
have anything to do with Belle Delphine
um well my girlfriend watched the video
and she was just
she was yes you'd be on piss oh so it
did have something to do with
Philadelphia but you know what I can't
kidding I'm genuine okay wait he was
pissed wait hold on hold on hold on
about which part yeah which tell me
everything the smelling of the spit the
really the last it was like two hours
ago where we we initially talked about
it and how you brought up how I Duggar
and stuff like that so oh my goodness
yeah I did this no but that was just it
was a ticking time bomb
this was bound now does she have
jealousy problems yeah oh wait and now I
feel bad cuz you I mean work we're
girlfriend alone
yeah I know no I'm not blaming you guys
yeah but hold on no I just wonder if she
understand but she knows our show no but
even still I think if you're gonna get
you can't get angry about a do it you
know no it's like it's he's not [ __ ]
him no no it's for the show all right so
I'm we're all goofy yeah I'm gonna do
anything interesting like I did anything
so yeah there were a lot of problems
with that and Wow I fell back so okay
interesting
well we'll send a message out to Bell
and let her know you're single are you
good to taste this bit now you're too
young you've got your whole life Eddy
single now I don't want to end send you
your early grave yeah yeah how do you
feel I'm okay uh how many people have
you had sex with in your life in my life
yeah
while you think you so hard just have to
think about it it's counting up come on
how old are you you like just finished
high school 21 what's the real answer
what do you what kind of math you doing
your head I mean six six people six
that's pretty that's a lot more affected
I mean have you seen this guy's here yes
I have
dude you did a lot you yeah yeah how
many girls you [ __ ] before her well
when I got out when I turned I got a
nice cool because I dropped a bunch of
weight so when I got on like tinder and
Bumble like that those those fair game
so you just went crazy huh yeah and so
were you kind of just are you looking
forward to doing that again now that
you're single I mean kinda but I need a
connection with someone first I'm not
the type of dude that can just go and
like you know get down I need to make I
can't believe that you just [ __ ] like
crazy on tinder that's great I didn't
have access to that bad that's what
tender not that I would not that anyone
would want to [ __ ] me I guess people I
guess people want to [ __ ] who's that I I
guess so
what kind of girls are you pulling on
they're like on a scale of 1 to 10 um
well since since the break-up I haven't
I've been before I've um all types
what do you mean ons oh no no no like a
scale of attractiveness oh um seven
eight seven strong 9s yeah
nine in LA 9 mm in LA now it's pretty
good you know I've been watching a lot
of UK reality shows and the people that
they I'm telling you the scales are way
ain't [ __ ] different over there I'm
gonna work work perception here in Los
Angeles California 9 that's like a
supermodel and you [ __ ] kidding me
who's a ten in your mind in my mind it
was like a it's like a let's say uh I
don't know but that's a perfect specimen
that's Helen of Troy who launched a
thousand ships
yeah like a gosh you're saying she's
just one
small terrible no no actually that there
was this one girl and she was actually
French she was up there so and what was
the lowest number you've you went
[Music]
probably like a five five eggs yeah mom
I didn't click like I said I need a
connection first before I can of course
we all need it I'm not I'm not a pig I'm
not an [ __ ]
no I didn't know I'm just some prayer I
thought you were gonna say want to be on
no no no so I'm impressed
good man we'll get out there shake your
dick you know have some fun just use
protection of course no you know of
course cuz every time you [ __ ] a girl
think about it like this with this one
was help Theodore I think is the best
way to convince a young man to use a
condom when you don't use a condom you
are virtually [ __ ] every dude she's
ever had sex with very true every dude
has ever put his dick inside of her you
are basically [ __ ] that guy without a
condom
so I mean seriously you got to wrap your
deck up it's so important yeah let alone
the whole baby thing I mean Jesus Christ
that's what plus my dad has really
emphasized that too so yeah it's really
important yeah yeah okay well I guess
that's that oh yeah
II let you have any comments or uh
anything to add I I'm still sad that
they broke up you and I don't know that
I don't know the relationship at all
it's okay it was yeah I appreciate that
but it it's it's it is what it is is
what it is mm-hmm well I'm sure she's a
sweet girl and my heart goes out to her
she was the one that was dumped I'm so
why you good I what did you just say no
said yeah sorry I don't know why you're
getting all the sympathy you're the one
who dumped her so shut out the hair it's
obvious you got some big strange dick
now since after the break-up what was
she on a scale of one you know I'm not
gonna make you do that yeah yeah I'm on
to bigger and better things so oh well
come on
what I don't know I was just where I was
just imagine she was listening no no no
no I I just I'm at a different I'm in a
really good place in my life and it's
just it's for it's for the best
okay okay good I'm glad you're okay yeah
and I'm sure she's gonna find some huge
crazy [ __ ] weird [ __ ] and she's just
gonna be over the moon appreciate that
yeah yeah all right I guess let's move
it on scooter people are wild after this
I want to I want to go right into the
testing Bell spit but I want to first
prove to you guys the people you know
these people that ride scooters mobility
scooters on the street mm-hmm they're
crazy they are crazy mm-hmm and I'm
gonna prove that and a thesis here today
I have documented proof here's one dude
is doing a hula hoop fire a girl and the
who who falls the fire is having trouble
all right having some trouble with the
flaming boolittle and no me on a
mobility scooter came to the rescue
that was the safe so homie on a mobility
scooter came jamming and he just took it
out I guess an effort to put out the
flame I'm not sure why he figured that
would help anyway if anything he would
just spread the fire her you know
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
discuss so easily I've got this I've got
this yeah I don't care what anyone says
he just destroyed all right quick yeah
it's stuck in his spokes and he's trying
to back out and get out he's that guy
definitely saved the day okay what a
hero you know what makes me want to
watch that fireman clip that was in the
Gustav
can you pull that for me down yeah again
yeah surprise you pass that over
actually well it was just too short but
I think in the context of this clip and
fireworks really well
oh wait that link didn't work sorry hold
on one sec oh did you change the name of
our chat to a lady nice what are you
talking about Oh dance trial infused
about it
so ela speaking of fire this is some
kind of demonstration I guess there's a
lot of people around in cameras there's
a man in a red suit was presumably a
fireman so Matt yes it's a guy I think
yes and there's lots of cameraman
impressed so presumably he's about to do
some kind of feat here with fire and
Technic I would assume and so what what
pursues is especially incredible in
which you'll find out as I play this but
maybe Elia you can attempt to explain
this clip to me because I have a hard
time understanding it
[Laughter]
so he goes to light the the log and
explodes in his face but then Danny's
got like a cup of fire you know I just
and I know there's a dude on fire so
like I was watching last night I kept
laughing I think I know there's a dude
on fire I have a feeling it's like it
goes right out it's like boy he just
running in circles like imagine your
fire like he's on fire and he calmly
takes a cup of fire any like just pours
on some Oh me next
I mean that's the poor fire firefighting
right there from beginning to end he
just scooped it right on him by the way
I'm sure they're both fine why is there
so many people gathered around he's just
setting some laws like it's a fire
safety I just wanna say like you know
how when you have fluid it burns the
fluid off really fast so I'm pretty sure
those guys were fine they must have been
totally fine but just the way he scoops
the fire on this reporter he just he's
so packed and so brave fire all of her
looks like he was a marketing badass
like accidentally the first thing it
looks like a firebender from it's true
but like this firefighter like I can't
imagine you being worse at firing fires
first it blows up in his face he's on
fire then he goes out of his way to
light as many people on the fire as
possible and he just burp annex Oh mate
is so funny I'm never like being on fire
never been so fun that's that's a fire
training video right there good good so
there you have it
fired safety 101 folks I think that was
a fire safety video what did he have
like something so flammable and liquid
in his hand was like a cup of fire I'm
assuming it's whatever he he put on the
stack of law guys he put like a ton of
fluid oh that guy did his job
[Music]
anyway it's back to the scooter my
thesis about scooter people being crazy
here's one right here you tell me what
you think of this dude I'm telling you
like this lady first of all she had
plenty of time to react the doors open
and she still came slamming out and I
bet you anything this lady in the
scooters pissed at her you know what I
mean they're out doing their own thing
it's for some reason like crazy scooter
people just not they go fast yeah and
they don't care like the whole world's
got to look out for you therefore these
scooter people they go so fast dude
and they just don't care and it's
everyone's fault is in their way they're
super defensive too like excuse me sir
like you're in a big-ass scooter going
through a tight aisle and it's like
excuse me sir excuse me and I mean this
is proof right here I can't
anything she was angry at this girl what
are you doing
watch where you're going you know I
can't hear how much time did she have
direct that how fast was she like
assuming she did react how fast have to
be going right and it's just like a
pedestrian sidewalk like she's really
boning out yeah so my in conclusion
scooter people are crazy right that's
right I'm sure plenty of people that use
them are people but no but what I was
gonna say is is I personally okay you're
supporting my thesis yes because I don't
want to hear any logic or rationale I'm
trying not to paint too broad there's no
there's no a coalition of scooter people
they're gonna come out there in a
neighborhood I used to live in there
were two women two very heavyset women
that would roll around the neighborhood
all the time just in the middle of the
street it was two of them side by side
and yeah they would they would like
scream at cars for going too fast by
them and stuff it's like what are you
funny doing you're like that reminds me
there was there's a scooter later who
does that and films herself yelling at
cars
then they saw yes yeah she's she's sort
of infamous not just cars pedestrians
everybody I'm wonder if this is her
we're so far from our ending point isn't
of this episode just gonna do pal spin
we they all business we started doing
two episodes of the week and all of a
sudden I I have I don't have enough time
to talk about everything the the content
gods are they're tricky they like to
[ __ ] with us because when we were there
was there's been drought periods where
it's it's difficult to find funny goose
but lately we're doing two episodes a
week and we can't even get to everything
I have so much [ __ ] left I want to talk
about I guess we'll just have to wait
till Tuesday and hope that nothing
happens between now and then
I really like that alright well on to
our final story here as many of you know
we have an ongoing saga with Belle
Delphine the infamous anime cat girl
still banned from Instagram that seems
like it's permanent really hasn't come
back yet alright Wow
you know and I saw only on Twitter she
posted a really cryptic like she just
posted numbers an image of a number and
I have no idea what it was a countdown
she was like - what well I think it
seemed to stop at the time that she got
banned so maybe she she stopped what
happened after she was banned I thought
really yeah I'm gonna go check right now
but at any rate she had sent us a care
package in a video you guys may recall
of her drooling and spitting and licking
a jar of spit that she sent to us and we
had noticed when we opened the smell it
that it smelled strangely of alcohol
like very very strongly about Mahal and
we had theorized well I wonder if it
fermented but that didn't really make
sense because you need sugar in the
fermenting process there's a lot of
things that have to take place for
alcohol to be fermented because alcohol
is a byproduct of bacteria eating sugar
of some type oh that's why you get
alcohol from grapes or potato or green
bacteria feeds on the sugar and the
byproduct is alcohol Oh
dan says the countdown stop the day she
got banned oh man that must have really
hit her heart huh I mean it's probably
what does this mean she knew she was
gonna get bent I don't know it's at five
four three and the day the three was
posted was the day she got banned and
then it just stopped after that she
seems to just completely withdrawn from
you know what happened she flew way too
close to the Sun man she like all the
sudden everyone was talking about her on
the [ __ ] I mean on the news yeah I mean
Howard Stern I was talking about her she
flew too close to the damn Sun
and her pasties melted right off and
then su-kam was an that wasn't down but
was she posting like pornographic I mean
well borderline more I mean her nipples
were covered by them and she skirted as
close to the other line as possible you
know but her accountant was up for a
long time as far as I'm aware was
verified - hmm a lot of followers it's
no coincidence she got banned right
after all the media attention no she
definitely just got too popular too fast
but her patrons up and her meanie of her
means of supporting herself as her
patreon which is still up and yeah and
as far as I could tell gained a lot of
new supporters since all the new
coverage I'm sure so anyway she sent us
spit and well I got this interesting
email in our podcast a trace
reproductions fan mail account I'm gonna
read the email to you and then when I'm
done reading this email I'm going to
apply this alcohol testing kit to her
spit and I want to see if we can't learn
some new digs
okay from Laura she says totally bizarre
subject but I had the right and with
some facts was after hearing you guys
state the Belle Delphine spit spelled
smelled strongly of alcohol and comments
that it was likely fermenting spit does
contain an M site called analyze that
can breakdown unfermented carbohydrates
into sugars and there's an ancient
method of making alcohol that involves
spitting but our mouths do not contain
yeast if they did say in the case of an
oral yeast infection the candidate the
can the candida albicans not anywhere
near the amount of yeast needed to
kick-start any type of fermentation on
its own the booths above is made by
boiling corn or rice chewing it spitting
it out and continuing the recipe or have
the sugars needed to begin the fermented
fermentation process sugar is a crucial
step in fermentation
if you look at the videos Claire she was
she has something aiding her while she
spits some parts are just too watery to
be spit it was a thought when we were
watching like how there was a low maybe
I should show the video as I discuss it
now [ __ ] it I'm just gonna get into it
it's got time for this [ __ ] yeah there
was a lot of spit and I was impressed
she was like God I must have taken a
long time to produce that many much spit
you look at videos just clearly
something aiding or spit some parts are
we should show it I mean you know let's
show it it's on your computer yeah it's
on my computer it's on the desktop now
this one was safe for consumption right
I mean we didn't get in trouble for the
yeah it seemed to be fine
so here it is again I'll read this email
as this goes and Zack feel free to be it
off now that you're single 10-4
so I mean that's real spit that's
definitely spit but then all the sudden
there's like a ton of it in the glass
like if you look at the glass there's a
cut and then the volume increases a lot
so yeah right there right there right
there that's a lot more yeah so right
there I'll pause it right there yeah
like suddenly at this point really
analyzing this but I think I need some
time yeah dude people would pay just for
this frame but I think at this point
right here like that's all spit and then
here there's a ton of opponent yep so I
think she just poured something pour
something or or headless liquid in her
mouth and submitted in to increase the
volume some parts are just too watery
and anyone who does have a DNA test
knows it takes a long time to fill up a
tiny vial of your mouth I've zeroed out
that if you receive primarily was not
spit if you're smelling alcohol that's
because there's actual alcohol in there
zero chances due to firm
unless she added a pack of Fishman's
yeast in there Fleischmann sorry Dan
apologies did Dan apologize to mr.
Fleishman apology I'm not apologizing
Fleischmann he's fine he doesn't need to
apology simple way to knows if you go on
Amazon and buy some cheap tests there
are little strips that look like cheap
pregnancy tests that you can swirl in
the liquid will come back positive or
negative I personally think she would
send you anything that actually came
from her body because of the fact that
she or her manager would be concerned
that somebody would just do that a drug
test STD test 23andme tests on it you
could find out an unbelievable amount of
info about a person just from their spit
and if they had any common sense they
would send a substitute in college I did
work for a lab in Boston that did an
array of genetic testing and spit still
looks like spit when received even
months later interesting especially if
it was an airtight jar similar to what
Bell sent you I bet my right arm this
was a bait and switch and that you were
sent a solution of whatever she had
around her house and she thought she
could pass it as spit likely alcohol
mixed with something else love the show
and congrats on the baby so this person
first of all I'm [ __ ] outraged if
this is true I want a new dog spit well
what I could what I can tell is that
looks like it looks like it's partially
spit and then some other alcohol so
let's grab a chunk in there and oh
there's chunks in there dude that is
[ __ ] there's literally [ __ ] growing in
here now there's air bubbles air bubble
smell well I'm having a close hold on
that this is gross so from what I can
tell there is spit and this is
interesting because what this test is is
a saliva screening test for detection of
blood alcohol so this is for like
seeing if a person is drunk or not and
it and the way that it measures it
doesn't like if you put it in a just a
pure alcohol or beer something it'll be
so dark that it because here it measures
like point zero two point zero four
point zero eight point three percent
alcohol which is very little so if you
just took a glass of water and put like
a drop of alcohol in it that's what this
measures anything more than that it
would just go dark so if it shows up on
this it means that it is such a small
percent of alcohol that it's likely from
the result of her drinking it and not
just pouring it in mm-hmm
you know what I mean so you put it in
there for five seconds then remove this
is so gross and then you wait two
minutes to compare color yeah I got a
timer ready back here oh so here we go
so how long do i swish it for five
seconds you don't swish it you just put
it and just dab it oh god this is so
gross I feel like I'm gonna get a new
like a undiscovered STD okay
like we're breeding a new SCD in there a
lot of air came out yo was it hissing
yeah hiss so five seconds okay take it
out yeah that should be good oh no my
finger touched the liquid so it's
already turning green i'm i'd started
the timer actually
oh it's vinegary now yeah it's got a
vinegary smell now it's got it's gotten
a little sour oh wow
it's coming at really dark so now you
compare it to the colors yeah so we're
gonna let that sit yeah there's
definitely alcohol in it the question is
how dark is it cuz basically that'll
mean does she actually was she drinking
at the time and spitting it in or did
she just pour alcohol in here for some
reason yeah if it gets like completely
solid green I would say she just poured
it in
which kind of makes sense if you want to
just make sure we can't do anything
wherever there's spit like sent like
analyze it but I owe to like sterilize
it that's an interesting ya theory but
the thing is I can tell you right now
looking at this strip it's not sterile
smells like that we are doing this far
this is for science Laura
Oh for Laura right well I thought that
email was so great and I just figured so
I can already tell you that this color
is coming in not at the darkest level
that would indicate that it was just
poured in as alcohol that's what this is
what is this is indicating to me is a
blood-alcohol level of about 0.8 which
means she was definitely drinking
alcohol and I think that what she gave
us what I think this indicates is that
it was spit and she was just drinking
alcohol at the time I mean I find it
very unlikely that she would have just
combined water with you know 0.8%
alcohol that's not that's not likely
right I mean that's impossible
we're still waiting for two minutes
right we just hit it yeah whatever it's
at now is definitely not the darkest
color it's basically a notch above the
darkest no it's there it's right there
no it's yeah that one so here we have it
and this is scientific here right from
the yeah what do you guys think put it
next to the one I think it's yeah point
away so that's way too specific of a
gauge so what do we end in my is my
analysis correct do you think so shoot
you think she was drunk how old is she I
think she's at she's yeah also in UK
they just like Israel right beer it like
six and you can know which I think she's
over 21
yeah even though she looks 12 yeah so is
she drinking to help um get it going but
his point home 0.08 is the legal limit
to drive here in the United States uh I
think it's two for an average-size I
would be drunk she's having a good time
she's a young girl and she's having fun
I guess why not I mean too liquidy I
don't know I'm confused
but it's possible you know she was
probably mixing her saliva with liquid
in her mouth to produce more gross so
Zack how are you feeling at this current
moment I'm a little disappointed to tell
you the truth well there's definitely
spit in there now don't worry
yeah so yeah Wow yeah we get it I don't
know what we prove more confusing yeah
so many more questions it's getting
darker but we've moved by it mister yeah
we mr. time I think if you predicted an
actual alcohol which we can test damn
bring me in a shot of alcohol all right
pure alcohol and let's do a test and see
because I have a feeling that's just
gonna go immediately green dark like I
don't know what's the point of this even
we're just trying to basically well I I
anticipated being trolled right and I
didn't want to be bait and switched I
did not want to be bamboozled by her
mm-hmm and so I feel like we're getting
to the bottom of this this is important
so what do we have here Dan Barker Craig
is good so now we have pure alcohol not
pure alcohol but you know vodka I'm
gonna tip this in and we're gonna see I
think it's c'mon do three or all right
yeah let's see what let's see if this
well it's going green quick that's for
sure but if it ends up the same as hers
then that'll be really confusing that'll
be yeah no it's going dark yeah that's
that's gonna because it's you can see oh
yeah that's the dark that's
that's yeah and that's going to Subaru
yes hers didn't do but again see this
one's been right I've been getting but I
mean that's it does say the only way two
minutes it might just continue to dark
yet does but it definitely don't look
like that right right right right here
so this one you can see even after just
like a minute
the difference that's that's pure
alcohol yep
can you see it Dan yeah well you you
guys trust me so so I think that proves
that we weren't bamboozled in some way
seemingly that would prove there's some
spit in there some percentage so thank
you so then we will so we're gonna
continue the saga we should get the 23
meet report back I'm not awake now I'm
kidding I would never do that
it's funny and this and this email Laura
says her or her manager would never send
spit I don't think I would have thought
of that had I been in her position do
you think they would have considered
that I'm not sure they would have I
don't know I feel maybe not at first but
then you it start something away it
should I not do more than me meaning she
probably has mailed spit before oh and
then it had probably occurred to her
that way we're not I thought we were
special with he is like the first time
so we have many more tests here how do
we use this well next time we're
drinking in here I think we should
administer ourselves to see how drunk we
are it's gonna do cuz it's for saliva
you put it in your mouth and then tells
you how drunk you are hmm
I guess but look at this [ __ ] is like
black it's literally after two minutes
oh my god show you yeah that's like
you're dead if that's your spit you're
[ __ ] dead oh you're dead one for black
they just says you're dead and finally
you know I want to talk about this
at two hours while having too much fun
[Music]
did you guys watch the molar testimony
not all seven hours of it but yeah I
watched a decent amount of it
you call yourself a patriot I feel I'm
gonna tell you I feel bad for this guy
molar really I do because everybody
hates him it feels like now everybody
hates him oh I see I mean right both
sides there the Republicans are accusing
them of taking part in a conspiracy and
now the Democrats like I saw a tweet by
Michael Moore here actually I mean can
you pull that up Michael Moore tweeted
about okay and like tossed just [ __ ]
Michael Moore [ __ ] all over molar and
then all these conservative media
started running the story about how even
liberals are now throwing Muller molar
bus and I'm like it just seems to me
like this guy is just a straight shooter
who's trying to do his job at a time
when everyone's acting crazy crazy it
seems like everybody just wants people
to just do their job and be law of the
country I'm assuming you're talking
about this one I just liked it he let's
have a look yeah this is it
he says like more darling of the left a
frail old man unable to remember things
stumbling refusing to answer basic
questions I said it in 2017 and Muller
confirmed it today all you pundits and
moderates and lame Dems who told the
public to put their faith and the
esteemed robber molar just shut the [ __ ]
up from now on and it finally not the
people who are retweeting this and and
reporting this are or a conservative
media of course cuz it's Michael Moore
who's you know liberal bogeyman for
decades at this point to them but I
think the point that I'm trying to make
is that everybody hates this guy now
who's just trying to do his job I feel
like he's a straight shooter he's
stickler and everybody keeps telling
everyone else just do your job and be
professional and he's the only one
that's actually doing his [ __ ] job
and everyone hates him for it am I wrong
about that
well is it right to say that everybody
hates them for it I mean Michael Moore's
further left than the average Democrat
well the guy is getting an unbelievable
amount of [ __ ] from everybody it seems
like right but he's really just doing
his job so I just feel bad for him I
don't know if that's it that's not
really interesting tech is it I don't
know I hate everything about everything
regarding politics right it's hard to
get into a head at all it's all just
hysteria right now I feel like the whole
everyone hyped it so much the mauler
part the mauler
yeah well I I guess I why are you hyping
it so much when right what is gonna
happen well I guess that's Michael's
point that he's speaking to his fellow
the leftists who like if he watched the
late-night show for the past few years
everything's like Moeller is gonna you
know like they's coming for you yeah
yeah really
it's mother time yeah yeah those memes
are cringy is [ __ ] but it's funny when
you do see him he really is just he's a
he's he's just a dude [ __ ] doing his
job yeah I know I don't know
and furthermore I mean he did exactly
what he stated he was gonna do which is
just refer people say that the report
that he made it speaks for itself and
just refer people to it and he basically
just did that for seven hours straight
so you know a lot of people were waiting
for him to make an epic speech and
totally own Donald Trump into and into
the jail so but that wasn't gonna happen
I think some people hoped that he would
have more balls I guess to to do
something more more I don't know they've
watched too much West Wing yeah I guess
that's not really the real world
yeah but he's like I have to say that
what I saw is 10 is equal to treason
Trump needs to be a peach and he be
prynt like if people were expecting some
movie theater under here or like bend
their rules because you're on the more
he's gonna fall on a sword even though
he's like a lifetime politician
apparently this is like his 50 some
think the time in front of Congress like
he has done this so many times he is a
lifetime he's like a war veteran Purple
Heart recipient he served in the FBI for
the majority of his life the guy is a
patriot he has worked hard and long and
service of this country and I do feel
like he's getting [ __ ] on by everyone
and I feel like it just sucks that at
the end of his like long and illustrious
career of servitude and interest of this
country that you've got the President on
one hand and all this acolytes saying
that he's a conspiracy there is he's an
angry Democrat even though he's been a
lifetime Republican and then you've got
people like Michael Moore calling him a
Fripp like frail old man unable to
remember things stumbling refusing it's
like dude what the [ __ ]
I saw Bill Maher on one of his episodes
talked about how he was disappointed
with him and yeah he was saying how
people make change sometimes have to not
follow the rules basically well [ __ ] you
you know it's not your life were
expecting him maybe to not follow the
rules because when they built up this
whole image of it I mean they [ __ ]
SNL had Robert De Niro playing him you
know what I mean like they built up this
big expectation that he's this badass
hotshot prosecutor or whatever wait this
is a job he's not who he really is
made a good job investigating he lot
[ __ ] arrested the hell out of a lot
of people that is true he uncovered a
lot of corruption you know but
ultimately this is a man who has spent
his life serving the country and I feel
like everybody's just [ __ ] on him
cuz I don't know you know it's like
you're a public servant and then you get
charged with this task he didn't ask for
it he got charged with the and then
you're in the middle of a [ __ ]
hurricane I'm team Moeller
it's Muller times
it sound so awful I just want him to
live a nice peaceful life now I want to
spend some time with his family you know
am I wrong am I so wrong to have empathy
for him I feel bad I don't know enough
about his job or what he could have done
that he didn't do hmm I don't know
enough and that's why I hate politics
cuz no one knows anything it kind of
feels like nobody know I don't know
what's going on behind those doors and
what kind of meetings that people are
having
I mean feels like even Trump doesn't
know he like goes on Twitter and starts
raving like a lunatic and it's like even
even the president I feel like doesn't
know what's going on anything's venues
are just chasing ratings yeah and then
all the news just me or just yet they
don't find out that I'm into the fake
news I hate that argument too but but
it's true you really nobody knows
anything anymore so I've always hated
politics because what what I'm gonna
start arguing with you based on some
information that someone else gave me
that I don't even know you know when
like I catch myself doing this this is a
human emotion and it's you feel like the
biggest idiot ever but when you hear
something a fact or a story or whatever
that somebody else said somewhere else
and then you remember that and you Reese
say it yeah as fact and then as you're
saying it you realize you're you're
reporting something as fact then you
remember her I just heard this guy
saying yeah that guy doesn't know [ __ ]
you know well you reported as fact
that's politics in a nutshell I feel
like that's everybody in politics is
doing that except for like maybe know
everybody sorry right
am i right Dan I mean I would I would
take exception to some individuals but I
think on the whole when anyone that
aren't just spitting out the line like
the boys know that are fair on the boots
on the ground
regular people aren't actually everybody
yeah I mean yes I think about any
Sanders and knows what he's talking
about bernie is a four he he definitely
has a first-hand account he's an
original
Bernie's an original love him or hate
him he's an original and now all the
Dems are just pile of him I'm not afraid
to say that I love him yeah he's an
original right Dan Original Gangster is
that what you're saying yeah no III
agree with that and then round now huh
the strip is like brown Jesus
oh that's the vodka one yes yeah okay
the Bell one actually weirdly it looks
like it's turning into like bright red
and it's crawling that normal hmm yeah
not sure about that I hope that was okay
too I feel bad that her Instagram was
was uh have you not heard from her since
no two interaction where she sent the
Nowak äj-- huh well they're not like in
contact know she yeah there's only been
two DMS yes from address yeah and she
asked me if I got it right okay that was
it huh
and then she asked me for a picture of
my dick and obviously that's mine
[Laughter]
I guess yeah I mean I guess she just
fully just decided to take a break from
being online because of all the [ __ ]
she had laid on patreon
let's see patreon oh don't think not
gonna be I'm not sure I just want to see
if there's new posts Wow her patrons run
up a lot I think she had like 3,600 and
now she's at 4449 that's people yeah
yeah well let me let me crunch some
numbers here cuz she's got a one dog
here that gets you nothing he's got a $5
tier that pretty much gets you nothing
and she's got a $25 tier well the one
tier that really matters here I think is
the snapchat right Zach comment how much
do you pay for that one $50 what is that
50 [ __ ] dollars to get nurse Yap shot
per month hitting me what does that give
you so the snapchat isn't when is her
basically her nudes huh bath shower time
panty shots cosplay photos very
not-safe-for-work
pics and naughty videos
so I feel like that's really the tears
before that is just like pictures and
[ __ ] that's on the Internet's a
conservative or fair estimate that like
half of her subscribers at least yeah I
don't see the what are you doing in fact
I think because Dan because she probably
does have a couple of lunatics that do
the king and God support right which is
twenty five hundred I think we can
safely assume her average is 50 per user
hmm I do think that I mean if that's the
case I mean she's making almost a
quarter of a million dollars a month off
of really I believe that I would I would
make a more conservative estimate but
she's I would say she's definitely
making at least 100k a month off the
patriot let's say 30 but again Dan you
know there's like a couple of dudes who
are paying her $1,200 a month yeah that
swings it hard yeah and I I just don't
see the point let's say 30 you know if
its third that still gives her 130 grand
yeah it's a good living so she's killing
it she's good life man let's see her
posts it doesn't show me that oh you
ain't had a good point that patreon does
take a cut I don't think it's that much
so yeah her last post was July 10th whoa
she is definitely she's gone she's out
Wow what don't oh wait did you go to the
post yeah
oh you're right July 10th huh I mean how
long has she been doing this she's
finally in the bank
it's like mm-hmm just going a long
vacation Zach is she active on our
snapchat too soon Zach you just broke up
yeah you're not allowed or is this
chilly or well if you're in a
relationship are you allowed to have a
subscription to her snapchat or is that
weird
no no yeah I was just asking for Zach
it's perfect you didn't know that well I
don't know it's looking at porn cheating
nobody you're just looking at free porn
versus paying a specific person
does a little different because you're
like infatuated with yeah
so king browsers like $10 a month is
different I wish it was $10 a month I
don't know how I would feel about it
even if you paid that one it's a little
too because there is so much free right
porn
wells that pays for porn he thinks oh no
no not an old on I don't pay for porn
anymore because the baldies higher Zac
said yeah well if you have the
membership while you were in
relationship no was in high school yeah
I got my parents credit card yeah yeah
interesting okay I've never paid for
porn as you well know I do know because
we have a joint bank that [ __ ] yeah I
don't actually check but no I mean yeah
not like we keep secret no but but I
didn't know that you would consider such
a thing you did at Elodie well how would
you feel if I i wouldn't feel good about
it but i think i thought guys got more
leeway because they're just [ __ ]
creeps by nature they are crabs but
that's another layer and something else
to peel back well it's like you're
specific what bra I didn't want the girl
or I do think pink for porn is already
kind of hard to it makes you an official
[ __ ] wears like you can be an unofficial
grip when you're watching free porn
right so a mind maybe I'm wrong but
that's not lame because if you're paying
I get okay no unless you do the couple
made a decision together to get the
membership because they watch it
together yeah no but I see your point
but I think you have to make an
exception for browsers because they just
make high quality stuff versus
subscribing to it
why are you know I don't I'm defending
the dudes out there
I don't I don't pay for porn you know
that mm-hmm but I don't think that
subscribing to browsers for a little
higher quality and stuff that by the way
is female friendly so that's why I'm not
talking about blacks com you can't pay
for black comic difference does it make
those on this laptop like canceling all
these yeah I'm drawing out the show so I
think but I agree that that subscribing
to a specific person that's definitely
another level for sure it's we're it is
stranger it would be unacceptable
stranger things
unacceptable I don't pay for cars I'm
not considering it I'm just I'm
exploring this territory well if any
dude out there is wondering if you want
any advice for me
keep it better or not no I don't know
his secrets you don't do it it's weird
you can't keep secrets just watch free
porn people all find out there's plenty
of free porn - just don't be so weird
just keep your [ __ ] together man or
right weight and everything like the
both of you know about it that's the way
to do it if you want to do it I'm like
honey I have something I need to tell
you I have I am thinking about getting a
browser subscription I'm not getting the
Platinum which just the gold I'm getting
the gold which i think is the best value
and I'd like your blessings we've been
married for 12 years and I'd like your
blessings on this browsers yes
subscription that is how you do it and
if she says no you don't get it well
there you go
that makes sense consent either I'd like
to tell you indication like I'd like
money I'm getting a bail Delphine
subscription don't worry it's not the
gods here but it's a little it's so much
money can you share it you [ __ ]
kidding me you got a share cost you
think you think there's a group of dudes
that like
we ship in on it like pay-per-view oh my
god they chip in like pay-per-view event
man if she bounced some of those horny
[ __ ] paying that's so much money she
can't she kind of got to keep it up for
them I wonder for snapchat you can't do
that probably right
do what just bounce on that why not I
guess they can leave if they want but
she doesn't yeah I don't think she's
obligated to do it yeah by patreon yeah
it's gonna get me [ __ ]
they discharged those cards every month
alright that's it I mean what a wuss I'm
exhausted I throat hurts I'm not
sleeping I'm so [ __ ] tired I want to
sleep a lot when I get home drink a soda
pop I got nothing to watch that's
bumming me out
I tried Big Brother and it sucks Oh
we tried like a random episode yeah I
couldn't find out how to watch it from
the beginning in I had a heart where do
you watch big brother or do you just
catch it when it's on we DVR we watch it
okay so I know what it's like at the
rate that we pay his ass young people I
mean we've never had cable we only got
it a year ago and I regret the minute we
got it
we watch a lot of stuff in our apartment
that's cool well I actually tried DVR on
it but I'm late to the game but I was
hoping that have it on fodder you Hulu
or something but I just couldn't find it
so we tried watching the new app and
there's like some heck hillbilly that
didn't get voted off and then he got
he's getting revenge on people but
what's really complicated it was too
complicated but then like the set was
felt like some why does this set feel
like camp Anna wanna that's that's the
theme of this season it's like summer
camp that's if you're so claustrophobic
in the house and there's like a detail
oh it's Jail
well it's basically boys I can't leave
how long are they in therefore they
can't leave they can't talk to their
loved ones they're not allowed to call
them they get yard
and some of the members get punished and
they're not allowed to eat I saw one of
the the punishment for that episode was
no she only cold showers and you had to
eat gruel for a week yeah it is Jail
cold showers and girl for a week at
least addicting but once you get all the
ins and outs of all you got it yeah you
got a no let's go holy [ __ ] the show
started in the year 2000 and it's on its
21st season I know I was like did they
have a channel here for Big Brother they
have it in Israel you can watch it 24/7
you just watch what's happening in the
house oh that's that's premium that's
like premium say that's that's Belle
Delphine high level browsers gold [ __ ] I
think oh really it is available yeah so
you have that you have membership to
that yeah what you're just watching the
live show is that infidelity
that's [ __ ] no okay so so CBS all
access is fine but for some reason Belle
Delphine $100.00 snapchat tier isn't
exact double-stranded consistent at
least what do you twitch staff they
should hire me yeah you could I wouldn't
take the job though you claim them haha
idiots you clean them up good I'm so
tired Theodore okay he's a tough kid man
but this is the weekend had a lot of fun
this week on the podcast hope you guys
didn't think we need next time we need
to do some baby updates oh yeah let's do
baby updates we got pictures he's gained
a lot of weight
he's messy but he's cute he's starting
to smile we'll get back we'll do some
baby updates on Tuesday yes the music
plan not yet but I mean you guys I hold
off because usually he talks so long
that the song ends late he'll go ahead
oh that's going on the show you know
we'll update you guys that it's hard
that's it it's hard being a mother and
in the first months are tough I was so
afraid of labor like I was so focused on
labor how
top I already forgot about that was
nothing no sleep there's nothing like a
baby that won't stop crying there's
nothing stressful like that and it's not
having to take care of them non-stop is
really you have to get used to that it's
like every three three hours or less
he's got to eat well you basically live
your life in like one hour increments
when he's sleeping
and you're like okay I have one hour to
just sit here right ela mm-hmm but he's
amazing and he started to smile yeah
that's when he smiles it's like but I
feel like I feel like people don't want
to complain about it maybe cuz then it's
like you're gonna look weird but I think
I do want to say that it's very hard
yeah
complain it it's hard well about to lose
you Ethan
well we'll talk more about it on Tuesday
won't bring baby updates will bring
videos and pictures and stuff but yeah
it's tough yeah and I think you're right
there's a weird thing about I already
feel bad that I even said it why cuz I
bet you're gonna get judged like you're
a bad parent why because it's hard yeah
I don't know it's not easy play it tech
like the not easy but Zack you are
[ __ ] fired
you are so [ __ ] fired he's already
out the door
songs ending well let's talk about on
Tuesday don't feel bad but I think
that's important to think about too
because there is stigma like parents
aren't allowed to complain and like
they're expected to there's a lot of
expectations and it's tough it's tough
and you feel bad as a parent when you're
not perfect and they're crying and you
don't know how to help them and you feel
like a failure as a parent and it's very
hard because I don't know what I don't
mean it's just it's hard and it's our
first child and you don't know what to
do is just it's very difficult in
confusing time and we're stressed
there's a lot of pressure there's a
little very little sleep so yeah your
regular and you shouldn't feel bad
you're just talking to you
can your truth and the world strip - you
already [ __ ] up Zack you can't make up
for it now this is what I do when I'm
super exhausted think we've seen that up
in a few times yeah yeah
all right who's gonna end this we'll see
you next Tuesday guys thanks for
watching bye bye
[Music]
[Music]